how are you Geordi I'm doing very how
you doing what is it what does it sound
like to you 9 years now in the National
Football League well not to be too picky
but it's actually 10 no kidding
how did I lose that one how do I loo ha
maybe you didn't cut the one when I
didn't play it to ACL but this is this
is 10 so that sounds better than 9 I'll
tell you okay so let me let me do this
again in its 10th year in the National
Football League Jordy Nelson on the show
now that is accurate how is that intro
it's not good that's great okay just
give me to die just I'm that way in golf
to just give me a mulligan you know I'm
always better look you're good player
B's are always better but 10 years now
in the National Football League how how
are you how are you different I guess in
the 10 years now that you've been in the
league
Jordy I think you understand a lot of
things if it's business aspect if it's
the game if it's the meetings you
understand your body and what you need
to do in order to be prepared for a
season so your minds a lot more relaxed
at practice you're not all stressed out
about a bunch of crazy little things
that's going on you can focus on the
gaming focus on different things you
want to try out throughout training camp
in order to improve and you always got
to change some things up try to get
better because everyone else is and
someone's there to try to take your job
and shake it down so it was missing just
sitting out the first preseason game
part of knowing what you need to do to
stay healthy and stay strong
absolutely so we're figuring some things
out body feels good though playing on
getting some action um this weekend in
Washington and you know it's good to get
back out there get hit a little bit get
comfortable the speed is obviously gonna
be a little faster than what is it
practice and get used to that so come
game one you're prepared so you would
say that you you do need preseason
action it yeah I mean need I don't know
but I want I want it I think it to get
out there to get hit going into last
year when I hardly did any training camp
and didn't do any preseason it was it's
different there you haven't been hitting
especially coming off the ACL I've been
hitting over a year and so it's a little
different and so you kind of get a
little taste of it get out there get
your feet wet a little bit again get
some adrenaline going and work on that
conditioning because there's nothing
like gametime conditioning and make sure
you're ready to go
so if you could wave a wand what would
be the perfect number of preseason games
for you and for most of your colleagues
in the National Football League best you
can tell I keep going back and forth on
to be honest with you because part of my
thinking too is if we take away
preseason games it's just going to add
more practices and I don't think any
guys want that either so but you can
look at our organization here in Green
Bay we keep a lot of late round draft
picks a lot of undrafted guys so and the
negative plenty of opportunities throw
practice and games you know I can see
going down to three maybe but my issue
with that is Kenny cancer is still going
to be the same so lengthwise so unless
you're cutting a week off training camp
I don't want to cut any games mmm I
don't think they're going to be cut in a
week off a training camp shorty that's
my worry so I mean to be honest with you
if I you know you look at last Thursday
you know the day befores blight the day
of the games you know for the veterans
it's like the day after is usually off
so if you take that game out those are
probably gonna be three practices so
it's another way to honestly for the
veteran guys to take care of their body
and make sure you're ready to go because
you'll get the two pie metal games or if
you get a little bit in the first game
it wasn't much so that's kind of my
mindset so I just I think we need to be
careful as players that we don't dive
into getting rid of preseason games and
keeping camp the same and we do more
practices instead of games and I'm not a
big fan of the dual practice when teams
go against other teams because to me
it's a preseason game how about this
then Jordy Nelson um let's just let me
help you okay let's just do away with
preseason and we do away with the
regular season as well and just
stipulate that the Packers will have
high expectations and Super Bowl hopes
will have a couple of tight games in the
first weeks of the season there will be
a midseason trough where everyone will
wonder what's wrong with the team if
Aaron Rodgers has a good relationship
with the coach he'll tell everybody to
either chill or relax and then go on a
superb run for your team why don't we
just stipulate that's going to happen to
what do you say yeah that works out it
makes things a little stressful but at
the end day you want to be in the
playoffs and Gators
that's what happened so it seems like
did I honestly describe most of your 10
seasons in the National Football League
very close so we usually have a little
roll everyone freaks out obviously in
this organization we have expectations
for ourselves sure fans do as well but
in the inside the locker room everyone's
come even last year one we're never a
four-game losing streak or whatever it
was and you know we didn't freak out we
stayed true to who we were we kept
working and we just knew we needed to
get over huff and we did stain thanks
our phone for us well I know what it was
like for me sitting on a couch or in a
studio watching 12 perform the way that
he did I honestly I've done this
football only thing with the NFL Network
now 14 years 15 seasons I have never
seen a quarterback as red-hot and walked
a walk after in a way talking to talk by
saying everyone should relax quite like
Aaron Rodgers what was it like for you
to be on the business end of a lot of
these throws to be in the meeting rooms
to be out on the field with him Jordy um
to be honest it's nothing different than
weeks before it's as an offense war
group I mean when we are clicking as a
group it's and obviously Aaron's leading
that group
we're very difficult to stop but also
make things can make things look very
easy and the nuts where I think people
get the idea that it's easy for us to go
out and do what we do and it's not it's
very a lot of work goes into it's very
fine-tuned it's very precise and when
you're Precision's off just a little bit
it only takes you know an inch here
their foot here and there and things
aren't clicking so that's why we
continue to grind out that's we were
watching the film I knew we weren't far
away from where we needed to be and a
lot of that was just taking care of the
football and once we did that we were in
position where we were usually are and
then it also helped to get more
production from the running game and
part of that was due to one of the now I
guess former members of your wide
receiver core and Ty Montgomery
how many running plays can you give
Jordy if possible is out to zero come on
that would be zero really yeah I
wouldn't look it wouldn't look too great
if I was in the backfield so do you
think so I mean have you never played
running back at all in your in your life
Jordy or you've always been a wideout
no I was quarterback in high school
better than Aaron but I like it but
never running back so and I wouldn't
want to play quarterback no neither at
one point so there's a couple years ago
I think when Aaron is out with his
collarbone and we had senator Wallace
and start he got hurt and Scott to
Levine went in and then Randall was out
for the game as well and I was
legitimately like one play away from
playing quarterback and that was not
going to be pretty so you went into the
game thinking it's possible you were on
the depth chart that you'd have to you'd
have to get out there yeah once I was
the third quarterback going in one
Seneca went down I think is in the first
possession I was like oh my goodness I
guess Scott goes down that's me
I can't we're in big trouble
no that's not true though I mean look at
Ullman's throwing a touchdown pass in
the playoffs you could do that Jordy I
really like three or four in college so
yeah there's a chance I don't know about
just like stepping back in the pocket
though and reading the defense okay well
I know you did everything at k-state
your records are largely intact there
now again since since you got off the
campus there in 2008 with the draft
before I let you go I know I know
Aaron's huge on Game of Thrones are you
are you big on that - Jordan no unlike
Aaron I have three kids at home so it's
more PBS style and Disney jr. joint talk
some wild kratts okay Mickey Mouse
Clubhouse
oh I can I've got a cars cars one but
not - right yeah on a decent car three I
have seen other cars - it's pretty good
it's better than tuba nozzle I would
rank it cars one cars three and then
cars - very bottom absolutely very
bottom I I wouldn't even come close to
cars - I wouldn't just I'm throwing that
out I'm just saying that it's not even
part of the mix I think we've seen cars
one like 700 times we've seen cars to
thank twice well I don't I don't want to
you know show off Jordy but I've got a
nine six and they soon to be four at
home okay
and I'm I'm locked in on Game of Thrones
and paw Patrol
okay I'm you know what I'm saying like I
can I can I can talk about the red
wedding and then also about the red
in paw patrol you know you go you're
very diverse and it's impressive I mean
how old are your kids seven two and five
months oh man you were in the soup yeah
we're we're doing good so no I know it's
great I mean please I wouldn't want it
any other way but yeah I'm your soul
though they keep sleeping the way they
are well that's not even taught it's
like Fight Club you don't want to talk
about that Jordy so hey look have a
great season we'll catch up with you
down the line and say everybody - in
Wisconsin for us okay I appreciate it
thanks Jordy Nelson Packers wide
receiver you're on the rich highs the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy